can you name two other members of the  royal family  you know there's Queen Elizabeth rest in  peace and he is still alive England's  royal family is getting a new member  dignity beauty and a little rule  breaking that's our American princess  thank you hi guys i'm lauren zima  Prince Harry and Megan Marcos wedding is  on Saturday May 19th and you want to be  in the know but we know that you are  busy so I'm here to help on spillin the  royalty get all the fashion the regal  refinement and of course the tea we're  even heading to Britain for the wedding  itself you have to have a hat you can't  go to the Royal Wedding without a hat  the people judge each other on the hands  of course exclusive interviews tutorials  and more the Royal Tiki laughs fill in  the royalty post new episodes every  Friday cheerio  [Music]